optimal at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking can I ask you a personal
question no it is soon I'm a cybernetic
organism living tissue over metal
endoskeleton this episode is brought to
you by audible which I've used for years
I love audiobooks and I have to to
recommend right off the bat number one
is pressed my favorite audiobook of all
time and that is the graveyard book by
Neil Gaiman the only audiobook I've
wanted to immediately listen to a second
time as soon as I finished it's amazing
you will thank me the graveyard book the
second is vagabonding Bhairav pots which
had a huge impact on my life and formed
the basis for a lot of what became the
4-hour workweek so all you need to do to
get your free 30-day trial is go to
audible.com forward slash Tim tea I am
and you can choose one of those two
books or you can choose from more great
options than you can possibly imagine so
that could be a book that could be a
magazine that can be a newspaper could
be a class it's that easy go to
audible.com forward slash Tim that's
audible.com forward slash Tim and grab a
book enjoy this episode is brought to
you by me undies if I'm not going
commando I'm in me Andes I have been
testing these underwear for three to
four months now pretty much every day
and in fact throughout a bunch of my
other underwear this morning and on the
road in the house they are extremely
comfortable they look good feel good
they are made of micro Modell 2 times
softer than cotton as scientifically
tested using the kalibata method sounds
very fancy of course and I get a lot of
compliments from the ladies for these
you don't get diaper but you don't get
the tired elastic band they look great
and they have underwear for both men and
women check out my undies com forward
slash Tim and you can see everything
I've been wearing they're ridiculous the
sublime everything in between including
my favorite which is called out and I
would be remiss if I didn't mention
there lounge
this is a new thing and I've been
wearing their lounge pants when I record
podcasts I've been wearing them out and
about when I'm walking the dog meeting
people for coffee and they are extremely
comfortable they're made from the same
material as the underwear but some of
them like the blue ones I have have
pockets so you can walk about without
seeming like you're off of your meds and
completely crazy so that is awesome and
if you're not happy with the first pair
you try on I assume that refers to the
underwear they'll refund you completely
and you can keep the pair each right on
for free but if you're that kind of
person you should be ashamed because
that's disgusting
me Andy's com4 slash Tim check it out
vas Kip neues my friends on the Internet
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where does my job to deconstruct
world-class performers of all types
tease out the habits routines tactics
tools favourite books etc that you can
use in this episode we are going to do a
highlight reel and invite back one of
our guests who was a huge surprise hit
Brene brown doctor Brene brown on
twitter at Brene brown burn a brand calm
is a research professor at the
University of Houston Graduate College
of Social Work Bernays 2010 TEDx Houston
talk the power of vulnerability probably
don't associate that with me but maybe
you will by the end of this has been
viewed more than 31 million times and is
one of the top 5 most viewed TED talks
in the world she has spent the past 13
years studying vulnerability courage
worthiness and shame Brene is the New
York Times bestselling author of daring
greatly the gifts of imperfection and
rising strong so this episode turned
into a therapy session of sorts for me
because I felt like I needed a lot of
help related to topics she has explored
and I thought I would give you a sample
of some of the highlights the things
that I applied to my own life and have
revisited many many times
cincin includes my commentary this is
really a sample of a small profile in
tools of Titan's which is my new book
tools of Titan's calm you should check
it out and that book does not have an
audio Edition there are too many
illustrations exercises all sorts of
stuff through
the book for that to be feasible right
now but I want to tease it I want to
give you a little Scooby Snack
so hopefully you get the text that is
the hardcover or Kindle edition for
yourself and all of your loved ones that
you care about don't leave them stranded
folks so I would be so callous and
selfish of you so please enjoy this
distilled collection of highlights from
dr. Brene brown and there are some other
goodies that follow that but I will
leave that a surprise for you to
experience so please enjoy this round 2
episode of highlights action-packed with
dr. Renee Brown a frayed and brave can
coexist you know this idea that we're
either courageous or [ __ ] is just
not true because most of us are afraid
and braid at the exact same moment all
day long my commentary this reminded me
of Cass D'Amato who was Mike Tyson's
legendary first coach and was just a
treasure trove of one-liners but he used
to tell his athletes the following
before big fights quote the hero and the
coward both feel the same thing but the
hero uses his fear projects it onto his
opponent while the coward runs it's the
same thing
fear but it's what you do with it that
matters and he in fact coached Tyson to
the point and Tyson I believe used to in
fact get extremely sick before his
fights much like Dean Martin before big
performances or any performances up
until the very end
Dean Martin in fact vomit backstage but
Tyson would start off very afraid in
effect and work himself up to the point
that gradually by the time he proceeded
to the ring he believed he was himself a
god I'm not recommending that
necessarily but the point being the hero
in the character feel the same thing
it's what they do with that fear that
makes them different
give discomfort it's due do you have any
ask or requests for all the people
listening I would just say keep being
part of the conversation about these
tougher about these tougher topics about
vulnerability about shame about being
brave just lean into some discomfort
because I think these what's the
seemingly impossible problems that we
have around race and have a phobia and
the environment and just the lack of
love sometimes are not going to be
solved in a comfortable way we can't
we've got it you know you have to choose
comfort or courage you just can't have
those
so I guess my ask would be more of a big
metaphysical ask that give vulnerability
a shot you know and give discomfort it's
do is I think there is a really strong
relationship between your willingness he
or she who's willing to be the most
uncomfortable is not only the bravest
that rises the fastest my commentary for
what it is worth because thousands of
people have highlighted this one of the
most common kindle highlights from the
4-hour workweek is actually very
complimentary to this and it is quote a
person's success in life can usually be
measured by the number of uncomfortable
conversations he or she is willing to
have and in fact when I am perhaps
vacillating between to do items or
wondering what the most important thing
is on my to-do list
it is generally that which makes me the
most uncomfortable
when I had the opportunity did I choose
courage over comfort Brene actually flew
under the radar for a very long time
until she came across Theodore
Roosevelt's Teddy's famous arena quote
and I'm just going to give you a piece
of it here and that is quote the credit
belongs to the man who is actually in
the arena whose face is marred by dust
and sweat and blood who strives
valiantly who errs who comes short again
and again because there is no effort
without error and shortcoming and
there's more to it of course she decided
at that point to teach as a public
figure to step out of not the shadows
necessarily but the corners into the
light
despite hurtful online comments and
attacks in that moment what I realized
is you know what I do want to live a
brave life I do want to live in the
arena and if you're going to live in the
arena
the only guarantee is you will get your
ass kicked and the second thing is that
Darin greatly is being vulnerable so
when you ask yourself did I dear greatly
today the big question I ask is did I
when I had the opportunity did I choose
courage over comfort my commentary this
is a great question also for daily
review for instance as part of the p.m.
review using something like the five
minute journal or other evening
journaling how that translates to more
than 30 million video views I went to
the Ted event and I experimented I
really kind of put myself out there I
talked about my own breakdown spiritual
whitening I talked about having to go to
therapy and how much I really hated that
I kind of thought it was [ __ ] like I
had to do it and I really put myself out
there I remember driving home and
thinking I will never do that again she
then watched the popularity of her video
absolutely explode now totaling more
than 31 million views on ted.com and
YouTube
and so if I look back so my learning my
takeaway from
that experience was this if I'm not a
little bit nauseous when I'm done I
probably did not show up like I should
have shown up one of her rules for
public speaking houselights so when I
rehearse in the traditional way we think
about rehearsing it's about what I'm
going to say and what I'm going to say
it and how I'm going to say it and so if
I do that what ends up happening I've
tried a couple times I get so like
prefrontal cortex I get so wrapped up
and Oh wasn't I supposed to pause here
and was I supposed to do this there that
I am NOT I'm not connecting and so for
me it is use images as the Ark
understand what image every image means
to me and what I want to wrap around
that image and then require that the
house lights are on so I can see
people's faces that's a good rule that's
a really good rule yeah so that thing
whether you know and I really really
allow any of my presentations to be
videotaped very very rarely because one
if they're taping you you have to be
super hot under the lights and the
audience has to be dark and then it's
performance not connection for me
shame versus guilt and shame and guilt
are very different shame is I am a bad
person
guilt is I did something bad so you go
out on Thursday night you get wasted
you're so hungover on Friday you sleep
through your alarm clock you miss a
really important meeting you get to work
late on Friday and your self-talk is
Jesus I'm a loser I'm an idiot
I'm such a loser that shame if you get
to work on Friday same scenario and your
self-talk is dude I cannot believe I did
that that was such a lame thing to do
that was such a stupid thing to do the
do
Frances shame as a focus on self guilt
as a focus on behavior to be trusted be
vulnerable it's interesting that you
talk about you know daily practices
because I think vulnerability is a daily
practice and for a lot of us you know at
least for me when it when it was new it
was about trying on new ways of being
and kind of testing it out one of the
things that emerged from the data is
this this idea of trust and the
relationship between trust and
vulnerability and people always ask me
you gain trust first and then you're
vulnerable with people but the truth is
you can't really earn trust over time
with people without being somewhat
vulnerable my commentary you should also
check out you can find all these
episodes at 4-hour workweek dot-com
forward slash podcast but Gabby Reese's
advice to go first as well as Neil
Strauss's pre-interview approach Jake
over in the text version and hopefully
soon the audio version of tools of
titans so check that who do you think of
when you hear the word successful you
know what's so weird I don't picture
anybody I picture the word redefine that
that is such a that has been such a
dangerous word in my research the word
successful yeah our success I agree that
I don't even use it anymore
because what does that mean like okay so
I am the CEO this company I make a [ __ ]
ton of money this is my title this is
the influence and power I have I'm on my
fourth marriage and no relationship with
my adult children right so I I think
when I hear the word successful my
answer is be clear that your ladder is
leaning against the right building do
you have any advice or what advice would
you give to your 30 year old self it's
okay to be afraid you don't have to be
so scary when you're scared huh meaning
what put on put on airs of confidence
and over
yes yes like the 30s are so exhausting
it's like the age yeah it is at the age
of perfecting proving pretending and
there's some liberation that can't you
know for me that came in my for there's
a breakdown of course that followed by
some liberation that came in my 40s so I
would just say stop hustling and now we
have a bonus for those of you who may be
interested this is the first chapter of
tools of titans contains some good
quotes some of my favorites it contains
some background on me that you may not
be familiar with as well as some
concepts and so on that you can apply
without even reading the book if you're
one of those bad people is not going to
even consider it so let's jump right
into it we'll start with some quotes
quote out on the edge you see all kinds
of things you can't see from the center
big undreamed-of things the people on
the edge see them first Kurt Vonnegut
quote routine an intelligent man is a
sign of ambition end quote
WH Auden I am a compulsive note-taker to
wit I've recorded nearly every workout
since age 18 or so roughly eight feet of
shelf space my home is occupied by
spying upon spine of notebook upon
notebook that mind you is just one
subject it extends to dozens some people
would call that OCD a lot of my friends
do and many would consider it a manic
wild goose chase but I do it simply it
is the collection of my life's recipes
my goal is to learn things once so that
I can use them forever for example let's
say I stumble upon a picture of myself
from June 5th 2007 and I think I really
wish I'd looked like that again well no
problem i crack open dusty vol 4 2007
review the eight weeks of training in
food logs preceding June 5 repeat them
and voila
I end up looking nearly the same as my
younger self - the hair probably it's
not always that easy but it often is
tools of Titan's like my other books is
a compendium of recipes for high
performance that I gathered from my own
use this is very important it was to
scratch my own itch there's one big
difference though I never planned on
publishing this
as I write this I'm sitting in a cafe in
Paris overlooking the Luxembourg garden
just off of Route sountrack rusyn Chuck
is likely the oldest road in Paris and
it has a very rich literary history
victor hugo lived a few blocks from
where I'm sitting Gertrude Stein drank
coffee f scott Fitzgerald socialized
within a stone's throw Hemingway himself
wandered up and down the sidewalks his
books percolating in his mind wine no
doubt percolating in his blood I came to
France take a break from everything
everything and by that I mean no social
media no email no social commitments no
set plans except for one project the
month have been set aside to review all
of the lessons I've learned from nearly
200 world-class performers I'd
interviewed on the Tim Ferriss show my
podcast which is now more than a hundred
million downloads the guests included
chess prodigies movie stars four-star
generals pro athletes and hedge fund
managers just to name a few
it's a broad spectrum and it was a
motley crew more than handful of them
had since become collaborators and
business and creative projects spanning
from investments to indie film and as a
result I'd absorbed a lot of their
wisdom outside of our recordings whether
over work outs wine infused jam sessions
text message exchanges dinners or
late-night phone calls and in every case
I'd gotten to know them well beyond the
superficial headlines in the media my
life had already improved in every area
as a result of the lessons I could
remember but that was just the tip of
the iceberg the vast majority of the
jams were still lodged in thousands upon
thousands of pages of transcripts and I
literally mean ten thousand plus pages
transcripts and hands scribbled notes
because of all that I had learned
outside of the recordings and more than
anything I longed for the chance to
distill everything into a playbook so
I'd set aside an entire month for review
and if I'm being honest lots of
chocolate croissant
to put together the ultimate cliff notes
for myself it would be the notebook to
end all notebooks something that could
help me in minutes and be read for a
lifetime
that was the lofty goal at least and I
wasn't sure what the result would be
exactly but within weeks of starting the
experience exceeded all expectations no
matter the situation I found myself in
something
in this book meaning tools of titans was
able to help now what I'm feeling stuck
trapped desperate angry conflicted or
simply unclear the first thing I do is
flip through these pages with a strong
cup of coffee in hand and so far the
needed medicine is popped out within
about 20 minutes of revisiting these
friends will now become your friends you
need a reassuring pat on the back
there's someone for that an unapologetic
slap in the face plenty of people for
that too someone to explain why your
fears are unfounded or why your excuses
are [ __ ] done plenty of people to
help there are a lot of powerful quotes
but this book is much more than a
compilation of quotes it is a toolkit
for changing your life because there are
many books full of interviews this is
different because I don't view myself as
an interviewer I view myself as an
experimenter I can't test something or
replicate results in the messy reality
of everyday life I'm just not interested
everything in these pages has been
vetted explored and applied to my own
life in some fashion I've used dozens of
these tactics and philosophies and
high-stakes negotiations high-risk
environments or large business dealings
the lessons have made me millions of
dollars and saved me years of wasted
effort and frustration they work when
you need them most some applications are
obvious at first glance while others are
subtle and will provoke something like a
holy [ __ ] now I get it
realization weeks later while you're
daydreaming in the shower about to fall
asleep
many of the one-liners teach volumes
some summarize excellence in an entire
field in one sense as Josh Waitzkin
chess prodigy and the inspiration behind
searching for Bobby Fischer might put it
these bite-sized learnings are a way to
quote learn the macro from the micro and
quote the process of piecing them
together was revelatory for me if I
thought I saw the matrix before I was
mistaken or I was only seeing 10% of it
still even that 10% these islands of
notes on individual mentors had already
changed my life and helped me 10x my
results but after revisiting more than a
hundred minds as part of the same fabric
things got very interesting very quickly
for the movie nerds among you is like
the end of the sixth sense or visual
suspects the red door knob the [ __ ]
Kobayashi coffee cup
I notice that it was right in front of
me the whole time well that's how I felt
and some piecing together patterns that
sometimes occurred a year and a half two
years apart to help you see the same
I've done my best to weave patterns
together throughout the book noting
where guests have complementary habits
beliefs and recommendations the
completed jigsaw puzzle is much greater
than the sum of its parts
so what makes these people different
well we'll start with a quote judge a
man by his questions rather than his
answers that is appear mark Gaston date
levies or levy I don't know how to
pronounce the French despite my time in
Paris I've been trying these world-class
performers do not have superpowers very
very important the rules they've crafted
for themselves allow the bending of
reality to such an extent that it may
seem that way but they've learned how to
do this and so can you these rules are
often simply uncommon habits and bigger
questions in a surprising number of
cases the power is in the absurd the
more absurd the more impossible seeming
the question the more profound the
answers take for instance a question
that serial billionaire Peter Thiel
likes to ask himself and others if you
have a ten-year plan of how to get
somewhere you should ask why can't you
do this in six months okay
so back to me for purposes of
illustration I might reword that and I
often do to myself what might you do to
accomplish your ten-year goals in the
next six months if you had a gun against
your head and out let's pause for a
second do I expect you to take ten
seconds to ponder this and then
magically accomplish ten years worth of
Dreams in the next few months no I don't
expect that but I do expect that the
question will productively break your
mind like a butterfly shattering a
chrysalis to merge with new capabilities
in other words the normal systems that
you have in place the social rules that
you forced upon yourself the standard
frameworks all of your assumptions that
you've carried with you they don't work
when answering a question like this
you're forced to shed artificial
constraints and you realize that you've
had the ability to renegotiate reality
all along in many cases and you'll come
up with a list of different options
maybe 90% of them are completely
worthless but it is the 10% that could
completely change your life in business
all of this just takes practice
my suggestion is that you spend real
time with the questions you'll find the
most ridiculous in this book 30 minutes
of stream-of-consciousness journaling
project detail more on page 224 could
change your life completely on top of
that while the world is a gold mine you
need to go digging in other people's
heads to unearth riches questions are
your pickaxes and competitive advantage
this book will give you an arsenal of
questions to choose from performance
enhancing details
that's the subheading and when
organizing all of this material for
myself I didn't want an onerous 37 step
program or something like that
I wanted low-hanging fruit with
immediate returns think of bite-sized
rules within these pages as peds that
usually stands for performance-enhancing
drugs but here it stands for performance
and enhancing details they can be added
to any training regimen so just think
different careers personal preferences
unique responsibilities etc to pour
gasoline on the fire of progress so
whether you have a mortgage and a bunch
of kids are no mortgage and no kids all
of these or many of them can be applied
to your Niek situation unfortunately 10x
results don't always require 10x effort
big changes can come in very very small
packages to dramatically change things
for you you don't necessarily need to
run a hundred mile race get a PhD or
completely reinvent yourself it's the
small things the very small things done
consistently
that are the big things for instance
practicing red teaming once per quarter
as say a General Stanley McChrystal or
Marc Andreessen might more often you
could listen to Tara Brock's guided
meditations like Maria Popova does and
credits it with changing her life the
specifically 2010 smile meditation by
Tara Brock which you can find online for
free
strategic fasting or exogenous ketones
these are things do not take a lot of
effort whatsoever and you can test them
very quickly you can test them tomorrow
you can test them this week and then you
throw a lot against the wall and you
figure out quickly what works for you
tool here as in tools of titans is
defined very broadly in this book it
includes routines books common self-talk
supplements favorite questions and
a lot more what do these people have in
common well in this book you'll
naturally look for common habits and
recommendations and you should do that
here are a few patterns some of them
odder than others more than 80% of the
interviewees have some form of daily
mindfulness or meditation practice so we
talked about a lot of different options
a surprising number of males not females
over 45 never eat breakfast or eat just
one meal per day that includes Leonard
Hamilton the undisputed king of big wave
surfing General Stanley McChrystal
and so on there are probably a dozen or
more examples of that many use the chili
pad device for cooling at bedtime to
find their optimal sleeping temperature
rave reviews of books like sapiens poor
Charlie's Almanac influence and man's
search for meaning among others and
there are some very very odd
documentaries that pop up repeatedly as
a favorite including many I had never
heard of here's a new one the habit of
listening to a single song on repeat for
focus almost like an external mantra
nearly everyone has done some form of
spec work they've completed projects on
their own time and dime then submitted
them to prospective buyers the belief of
course philosophies and foundational
beliefs are tools that failure is not
durable or variants thereof Robert
Rodriguez Robert Rodriguez is a good
example of that and almost every guest
has been able to take obvious weaknesses
weaknesses they've been told their
weaknesses and turn them into huge
competitive advantages Arnold
Schwarzenegger would be one example Dan
Carlin who is the creator of my favorite
podcast hardcore history would even say
copyright your faults and he goes into
the entire story of how he did that in
radio leading up to podcasting now of
course I will try to help you connect
all of these dots spot these types of
patterns but that's less than half of
the value of everything that we'll
discuss some of the most encouraging
workarounds are found in the outliers
it's very important to look for the
outliers and not throw out the baby with
the bathwater just because they seem odd
I want you to look for the black sheep
who fit your unique idiosyncrasies
keep an eye out for the non-traditional
paths like che Karl's journey from
manual laborer to YouTube star to
co-founder startup sold from the early a
billion dollars the variation is the
consistency as a software engineer might
say that's not a bug that's a feature so
borrow liberally combine uniquely and
create your own bespoke blueprint that
is how this works
all right now the following that I'm
going to read is specific to the book
but it's not specific to the book it
actually applies to a lot more so first
of all this book is a buffet and here's
how to get the most of it it's a 704
page book but I don't expect anyone to
read the entire thing and in fact if you
were to only read a hundred pages and
pick your favorites and dip in and dip
out just how it's designed like a choose
your own adventure book I would be
thrilled so rule number one
skip liberally I want you to skip
anything that doesn't grab you should be
fun to read and you shouldn't suffer
through anything if you hate shrimp
don't eat the goddamn shrimp in the
buffet skip it and my goal is for each
reader to like 50% of the book love 25%
of the book and never forget 10% here's
why
for the millions who've heard the
podcast and the dozens who preferred
this book that split was completely
different for every person
it blew me away I've had multiple guests
in this book people were the best at
what they do
proofread the exact same profile for me
answering the question of which 10%
would you absolutely keep in which 10%
when you absolutely cut and oftentimes
the 10% must keep of one Titan was
exactly the must cut of someone else so
this is not one-size-fits-all I expect
you to discard plenty so you should read
what you enjoy
rule number two and this applies to a
lot more than this book skip but do so
intelligently
okay so take a brief mental note of
anything you skip perhaps put a little
dot in the corner of the page or
highlight the headline could it be that
skipping and glossing over precisely
these topics or questions has created
blind spots bottlenecks and unresolved
issues in your life that was certainly
true for me when I looked at what I was
abit rly skipping it reminded me of a
question from Tara brach which related
the question of a mystic who said
there's really only one question worth
asking what is it that you are unwilling
to feel okay if you decide to flip past
something note it return to it later at
some point and ask why did I skip this
for instance did it offend you did it
seem beneath you seem too difficult and
did you arrive at that by thinking it
through yourself or is it a reflection
of biases inherited from your parents
family friends and others very often our
so-called beliefs are not our own at all
this type of practice is how you create
yourself instead of seeking to discover
yourself there is value in the latter
this discovery but it's mostly past
tense it's a rearview mirror looking out
the windshield is how you get where you
want to go now just remember two
principles and this applies to much more
than this book I was recently standing
in plus a Louie aha gone I have enough
I'm saying that correctly but I'll give
it a [ __ ] I give it a shot
it's a shaded outdoor nook on the river
Sun having a picnic with writing
students from the Paris American Academy
one woman pulled me aside glass of wine
in hand and asked what I hope to convey
in this book at its core now seconds
later we were pulled back into the fray
as the attendees were taking turns
talking about the circuitous paths that
brought them there that day nearly
everyone had a story of wanting to come
to Paris for years in some cases 30 or
40 years but assuming it was impossible
and I listened to their stories and I
was struck by a few things I pulled out
a scrap of paper and I jotted down my
answer to her question and remember that
was what did I hope to convey in this
book at the core
and I decided that I wanted to convey
the following two principles number one
success however you define that is
achievable if you collect the right
field-tested beliefs and habits someone
else has done your version of success
before and often many have done
something similar but you might ask what
about it first
like colonizing Mars well that is not an
out there still recipes look at empire
building of other types look at the
biggest decisions in the life of Robert
Moses for instance if you read the power
broker another fantastic book or simply
find someone who stepped up to do great
things that were deemed impossible at
the time like Walt Disney many of the
people in the book actually have done a
lot of reading on Walt Disney like
marking trees and even if they're at the
cutting edge of technology today which
Walt Disney was in his time there is
shared DNA that you can borrow principle
number two the superheroes that you have
in your mind those might be idols icons
Titans billionaires whoever are nearly
all walking flaws who have maximized one
or two strengths humans are imperfect
creatures and I really want to remedy
the problem of people romanticizing
those folks you might see on magazine
covers and putting them on a pedestal
you don't succeed because you have no
weaknesses you succeed because you find
your unique strengths and focus on
developing habits around them to make
this excruciatingly lay crystal clear
I've deliberately included two sections
in this book on pages 197 and 616 that
will make you think to yourself Wow Tim
Ferriss is a mess how the hell does he
ever get anything done everyone is
fighting a battle you know nothing about
so I wanted to tell you about some of
mine and what my down days look like my
bad days and some of my darkest periods
and how I get out of them the heroes in
this book are no different everyone
struggles so take solace in that now the
next section is on format I'm not going
to talk a lot about it because it's
really more relevant when you're going
through the text but there's a lot of
humor I point out a lot of patterns and
there's a lot of original material that
the book is comprised of three sections
healthy wealthy and wise it's a nod to
Ben Franklin and on top of that it's
actually very very clean way to organize
the advice from all these people
of course there's tremendous overlap
across the sections as all of these are
interdependent in fact you can think of
the three is a tripod upon which life is
balanced one needs all three healthy
wealthy and wise right health wealth and
wisdom to have any sustained success or
happiness and wealthy and the context of
this book also means a lot more than
money it extends to abundance and time
relationships and more my original
intention with the 4-hour workweek for
our body and for our chef was to create
a trilogy themed like I mentioned after
Ben Franklin's famous quote early to bed
and early to rise makes a man healthy
wealthy and wise even though I don't
really wake up that early people
constantly ask me what would you put in
the 4-hour workweek if you were to write
it again how would you update it and
they asked me the same thing for the
4-hour body in the 4-hour chef tools of
titans is in effect my answers for all
three so you could think of tools of
titans as the follow-up the sequel to
all three books at once okay we're
wrapping up shortly here so my send off
to you the three tools that allow all
the rest and I'm going to do a little
trial run of acting as audiobook
narrator in this one with trying to
voice different characters we'll see how
that goes all right here we go so he
Siddhartha by Hermann Hesse is
recommended by many many yes in this
book there's one takeaway that navall
rava Khan who is one of the most
successful entrepreneurs and investors
in Silicon Valley quietly dominating
many aspects of that entire game and
really a sort of philosopher king in his
own domain in a lot of respects he would
never say that but I will he is
reinforced with me several times by the
way side note when my Jamie Foxx episode
one podcast of the year in 2015
second place was Nivola rava Khan a name
that almost nobody knew just based on
the caliber and quality of the content
that he talked about and discussed and
shared and then episode so he's an
incredible guy but he's reinforced with
me personally several times on our long
walks
a story and the protagonist Siddhartha a
monk who looks like a beggar is that
he's come to the city and he falls in
love with a famous courtesan named
Kamala he attempts to court her and she
asks what do you have a well-known
merchant similarly asks what can you
give that you have learned his answer is
the same in both cases so I've included
the latter story here Siddhartha
ultimately acquires all that he wants
okay that's that's critical he starts
off with very very humble beginnings now
here we go let's try this out all right
I'm gonna I'm going to tell you who's
talking first here's the merchant if you
are without possessions
how can you give Siddhartha everyone
gives what he has the soldier gives
strength the merchant gives goods the
teacher instruction the farmer rice the
fisherman fish well very well and what
can you give what have you learned that
you can give I can think I can wait I
can fast is that all I think that is all
and what use are they for instance
fasting what good is that I don't know
why I'm making him from New Jersey
that's ok it is a great value sir if a
man has nothing to eat fasting is the
most intelligent thing he can do for
instance if siddhartha had not learned
to fast he would have had to seek some
kind of work today either from you or
elsewhere for hunger would have driven
him but as it is Siddhartha can wait
calmly he's not impatient he's not need
he can ward off hunger for a long time
and laugh at it ok that's the end of
that exchange and back to Tim here
I think of Siddhartha's answers often in
following terms I can think what does
that mean because you'll recall he was
asked what can he give what can you
teach what can he give I can think I can
wait I can fast all right I can think
this means having good rules for
decision-making and having good
questions you can ask yourself and
others I can wait
this to me means being able to play the
long game plan long term and not miss
allocate your resources I can fast this
means to me being able to withstand
difficulties in disaster it means
training yourself to be uncommon ly
resilient and to have a high pain
tolerance this book will help you to
develop all three of these things in
spades I created tools of titans because
it's the book that I've wanted my entire
life I hope you enjoy reading it as much
as I enjoyed writing it then I close off
with Buddha Buddha from the land of
Costa Rica of course Buddha Buddha
signed Tim Ferriss Paris France so thank
you for listening to that folks and I
suggest I implore I would so much enjoy
if you check out tools of Titan's it is
available everywhere you can find sample
chapters at tools of Titan's calm
including the foreword by Arnold
Schwarzenegger please consider for
yourself and for those you care about
it is is extremely extremely extensive
and easy to read it's fun it's the first
book that I've enjoyed writing so there
you have it tools of science calm it's
also available at Barnes & Noble books a
million Amazon iBooks Andy Bowne indigo
everywhere
so as always and until next time guys
thank you for listening hey guys this is
Tim again just a few more things before
you take off number one this is five
bullet Friday do you want to get a short
email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday that provides a little morsel of
fun before the weekend and 500 Friday is
a very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by me
undies if I'm not going commando I'm in
me on DS I have been testing these
underwear for three to four months now
pretty much everyday and in fact
throughout a bunch of my other underwear
this morning and on the road in the
house they are extremely comfortable
they look good feel good they are made
of micro Modell 2 times softer than
cotton as scientifically tested using
the kalibata method sounds very fancy of
course and I get a lot of compliments
from the ladies for these you don't get
to diaper but you don't get the tired
elastic band they look great and they
have underwear for both men and women
check out my undies com forward slash
Tim and you can see everything I've been
wearing they're ridiculous the sublime
everything in between including my
favorite which is called out and I would
be remiss if I didn't mention their
lounge pants this is a new thing and
I've been wearing their lounge pants
when I record podcasts I've been wearing
them out and about when I'm walking the
dog meeting people for coffee and
they are extremely comfortable they're
made from the same material as the
underwear but some of them like the blue
ones I have have pockets so you can walk
about without seeming like you're off of
your meds and completely crazy so that
is awesome and if you're not happy with
the first pair you try on I assume that
refers to the underwear they'll refund
you completely and you can keep the
Perry tried on for free but if you're
that kind of person you should be
ashamed because that's disgusting
me and these compote / Tim check it out
this episode is brought to you by
audible which I've used for years
I love audiobooks and I have to to
recommend right off the bat number one
is perhaps my favorite audiobook of all
time and that is the graveyard book by
Neil Gaiman the only audiobook I wanted
to immediately listen to a second time
as soon as I finished it's amazing
you will thank me the graveyard book the
second is vagabonding by Rolf pots which
had a huge impact on my life and formed
the basis for a lot of what became the
4-hour workweek so all you need to do to
get your free 30-day trial is go to
audible.com forward slash tim TI m and
you can choose one of those two books or
you can choose for more great options
than you can possibly imagine so that
can be a book that can be a magazine
that can be a newspaper it could be a
class it's that easy
go to audible.com forward slash Tim
that's audible.com forward slash Tim and
grab a book enjoy
[Applause]